U
IN THE STUDIO.
>> MAX, STAY SAFE THERE.
LET'S GO TO RICK REICHMUTH IN
THE WEATHER CENTER TO GIVE US AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
>> IF YOU HAVEN'T DOWNLOADED THE
FOX WEATHER APP, DO IT BECAUSE
YOU CAN GET A LIVESTREAM, IF YOU
LOSE POWER, YOU CAN GET LIVE
WEATHER COVERAGE, EVEN IF YOU
DON'T HAVE CABLE ANYMORE, OR
INTERNET, AS LONG AS YOU STILL
HAVE POWER OR-BATTERY STILL ON
YOUR PHONE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THESE IMAGES.
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE.
WIND SPEEDS HAVE BEEN AMAZING,
THE HIGHEST RECORDED WIND SPEEDS
WE'VE SEEN.
THE WIND GUSTS RIGHT THERE.
OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
SENSOR.
TO GET MEASUREMENTS LIKE THESE,
IT'S QUITE AMAZING.
THIS STORM CAME ON SHORE IN AT
CAYO COSTA, WHERE HURRICANE
CHARLEY CAME ON SHORE.
140-MILE-AN-HOUR SUSTAINED WINDS
NOW AFTER THE 155.
IT WILL CONTINUE TO WEAKEN.
STILL A HURRICANE WHEN IT EXITS
THE OTHER SIDE OF FLORIDA AFTER
TRAVELING ABOUT 140 MILES AN
HOUR OR SO IN THAT DIRECTION
FROM THE SOUTHWEST TOWARD THE
NORTHEAST, STILL LOOKING VERY
AMAZING ON SATELLITE
REPRESENTATION.
WE HAVE TORNADO CONCERNS ACROSS
THE EASTERN SIDE OF THE STATE.
THE TORNADO WATCH, A NEW ONE,
YOU SAY ISSUED, GOING UNTIL
10:00 THIS MORNING.
THE LATEST RADAR PICTURE, YOU
CAN SEE THE DARK REDS.
ONE LITTLE GREEN BOX.
THAT'S NOT FROM FLOODING FROM
STORM SURGE.
THAT'S FLASH FLOODING THAT'S
GOING ON HERE JUST FROM THE
RAINFALL.
THIS NORTHERN SIDE OF THE
EYEWALL HAS BEEN IN THAT FOR THE
LAST FOUR TO FIVE HOURS.
WE'RE GETTING INCREDIBLE
RAINFALL RATES.
THIS IS OUR EXCLUSIVE FOX MODEL.
WATCH WHAT WE EXPECT THIS TO
LOOK LIKE.
OVERNIGHT HOURS, AND BY THE TIME
WE GET TO TOMORROW WE'LL BE
WATCHING AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
WIND COME IN TOWARD THE
JACKSONVILLE AREA, THE ST. JOHN
RIVER WILL SEE A SPECTACULAR
STORM SURGE THERE.
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE STATE
GETTING A LOT OF STORM SURGE,
AND OBVIOUSLY ALL THE RAIN STILL
TO COME.
SOME SPOTS WELL OVER 12 INCHES
OF ADDITIONAL RAINFALL.
WE'LL SATISFY SOME SPOTS, AND
RAINFALL TOTALS OVER 2 FEET,
PUSHING 30 INCHES OR SO.
RIGHT HERE, THIS IS THROUGH
TOMORROW, A HIGH RISK FOR FLASH
FLOODING ON OTHER SIDE OF THE
STATE.
THAT'S NOT ISSUED VERY OFTEN.
JUST A COUPLE TIMES OF YEAR.
BE VERY CAREFUL TOWARD THE
EASTERN SIDE OF FLORIDA.
HURRICANE WARNINGS EVEN IN
PLACES LIKE DAYTONA BEACH.
ALSO TROPICAL STORM WARNINGS IN
EFFECT ACROSS GEORGIA AND SOUTH
CAROLINA.
ONCE THE STORM GETS BACK OUT
HERE INTO THE ATLANTIC, WE
EXPECT IT TO MAKE A LEFT-HAND
TURN, MAKE A SECONDARY LANDFALL,
PROBABLY AS A STRONG TROPICAL
STORM ACROSS PARTS OF GEORGIA
AND SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> RICK, YOU'RE SO GOOD AT THIS
STUFF.
REALLY WELL DONE THERE.
RICK, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
PATH THAT CHARLEY TOOK 18 YEARS
AGO, HOW SIMILAR THIS IS, WHAT'S
SURPRISED YOU ABOUT THIS STORM
THUS FAR?
>> INCREDIBLE SURPRISE TO SEE IT
MAKE LANDFALL IN THE EXACT SAME
SPOT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT YOU
COULD POSSIBLY HAVE TWO CAT FOUR
STORMS ANYWHERE ON THE U.S.
COASTLINE.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT MANY CAT FOUR
OR FIVE STORMS THAT COME ON
SHORE, AND TO HAVE IT THE EXACT
SAME SPOT IS A HORRIBLE THING
FOR PEOPLE AROUND FORT MYERS,
SANIBEL ISLAND, ALL THESE AREAS,
GETTING THIS IMPACT.
THE SAD PART ABOUT THIS STORM,
IT'S SO MUCH LARGER.
CHARLEY WAS A REALLY STRONG
STORM, BUT A REALLY QUICK AND
SMALL STORM.
THIS ONE IS JUST SO MUCH BIGGER.
THAT JUST MEANS THE IMPACTS ARE
THAT MUCH BIGGER.
BILL, SO MANY PEOPLE LIVE IN
FLORIDA NOW THAN DID 18 YEARS
AGO.
IT'S JUST LATTIMORE PEOPLE, A
LOT MORE INFRASTRUCTURE THERE
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH.
>> JESSICA WAS A QUESTION FOR
YOU.
>> HI, RICK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I WANT TO BUILD OFF WHAT YOU'RE
DISCUSSING, BECAUSE THE STORM IS
BUILDING SO SLOWLY, WHAT'S YOUR
EXPECTATION FOR HOW LONG IT WILL
TAKE FOR THE SYSTEM TO GO
THROUGH AND TURN INTO THE
TROPICAL STORM THAT HITS GEORGIA
AND SOUTH CAROLINA NEXT?
>> IT'S LIKE A FRIDAY NIGHT
LANDFALL, SOMEWHERE HERE ACROSS
GEORGIA AND SOUTH CAROLINA
FRIDAY NIGHT INTO SATURDAY
MORNING.
WE'VE GOT THIS ALL NIGHT TONIGHT
AND THROUGHOUT ALL THE DAY
TOMORROW, WE'LL BE WATCHING THIS
INCREDIBLE RAIN HERE, EVEN SOME
INTO FRIDAY, RAIN ESPECIALLY
ACROSS THE EASTERN SIDE OF THE
STATE.
WANT TO TELL YOU A LOT OF TIMES
YOU ALWAYS HEAR, MOST OF THE
TIME JUST THE RIGHT-HAND SIDE OF
A STORM, IS THE WORST.
THAT'S ALWAYS THE CASE FOR STORM
SURGE.
IT WAS THE CASE IN THIS ONE.
WE HAVE A LONG PERIOD TO STILL
GET THROUGH.
GETTING GOOD IMAGES FROM THE
STORM RIGHT NOW, THE STORM
COMING ON IN THE DAYLIGHT, WHICH
OFTENTIMES DOESN'T HAPPEN.
SO WE'RE GETTING SOME IMAGES
NOW.
A LOT OF PLACES STILL ARE NOT
ABLE TO BE REACHED.
THE STORM SURGE IS STILL IN
PLACE WHERE THE STORM SURGE CAME
ON SHORE.
SO IT'S GOING TO BE A WHILE
BEFORE WE GET IMAGES.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GETTING DARK.
IT WILL BE BEFORE TOMORROW
AFTERNOON BEFORE WE START TO GET
IMAGES OF THAT IMMEDIATE
COASTLINE.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, I JUST
RAMBLED ON THERE, JESS.
SORRY.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
JUDGE JEANINE HAS A QUESTION.
>> RICK, IT'S JEANINE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE WIND, HOW
STRONG THE WIND IS, THE RAIN IS
REALLY THE PROBLEM.
THE RAIN STOPS, THE WIND
CONTINUES THE FLOODING.
THE FLOODING IS THE BIGGER
PROBLEM.
>> MORE PEOPLE DIE FROM FLOODING
THAN THE WINDS.
IT'S FROM INLAND FLOODING.
ONE IS THE STORM SURGE, THE
BUBBLE OF WATER THAT GETS PUSHED
UP FROM THE WIND OF A HURRICANE,
AND THAT BUBBLE OF WATER PUSHES
ONSHORE.
THAT'S ONE PIECE OF FLOODING.
WHEN YOU HAVE WINDS THAT ARE IN
THE 150-MILE-AN-HOUR RANGE,
THAT'S INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS.
IT WILL RIP OFF ROOFS OF
PEOPLE'S HOMES.
IT WILL CAUSE A LOT OF POWER
OUTAGES.
IT WILL DESTROY MOBILE HOMES.
THERE'S THAT THREAT.
THEN YOU'RE RIGHT, THERE'S THE
FLOODING FROM THE RAIN.
BECAUSE THIS STORM IS MOVING
SLOWLY, WE GET MORE RAINFALL IN
THE SAME SPOT.
TOTALS OF 30 INCHES OF RAIN
ACROSS FLORIDA THAT'S ALREADY
SATURATED.
THEY'VE HAD A WET LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
THE GROUND IS SATURATED.
TREES ARE MORE UNSTABLE.
NOW YOU GET 30 INCHES OF RAIN
AND WINDS IN SOME SPOTS EVEN NOT
ON THE SHORE BUT GET 50,
60-MILE-AN-HOUR WINDS, CAUSING
DAMAGE AS WELL.
>> JESSE?
>> RICK, IN YOUR CAREER HAVE YOU
EVER SEEN A HURRICANE THIS BIG?
>> YES.
>> WHICH ONE?
>> KATRINA WAS HUGE.
IRMA WAS REALLY BIG.
AFTER KATRINA, RITA WAS REALLY
BIG.
IT DOES MATTER.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
155-MILE-AN-HOUR WINDS, THAT'S
NOT THE ENTIRE SIZE OF THE STORM
GETTING THAT.
THOSE ARE THE WINDS THAT ARE
CLOSEST TO THE CENTER OF THE
STORM.
THE STRONGER OR BIGGER A STORM,
THE WINDS EXTEND FARTHER OUT
FROM THE CENTER.
YOU HAVE MORE PEOPLE GETTING THE
STRONGER WINDS.
BUT AS FAR AS ACTUAL SIZE, THIS
HAPPENS FREQUENTLY, THAT WE GET
SOME VERY LARGE STORMS.
I THINK THE REASON WE'RE
COMPARING IT TO CHARLEY IS
BECAUSE CHARLEY HIT THE EXACT
SAME AREA AS A CAT FOUR STORM,
BUT A SMALL ONE.
A LARGER STORM IS GOING TO HAVE
BIGGER IMPACTS FOR A LOT MORE
PEOPLE.
>> RICK, I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT,
GOVERNOR DESANTIS IS DUE TO GIVE
ANOTHER PRESS CONFERENCE AT
5:30.
WHEN HE DOES THAT, WHAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'LL BE WANTING
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, HE'LL HAVE UPDATED
NUMBERS FOR US, I WOULD IMAGINE,
WHICH, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW WE'RE
OVER A MILLION PEOPLE WITHOUT
POWER, WITHOUT POWER GOING INTO
THE OVERNIGHT HOURS.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S REALLY WARM.
YOU DON'T HAVE WORRIES ABOUT
COLD.
WE'LL PROBABLY ALSO GET
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT KIND OF,
NOT JUST DAMAGE, BUT WATER
RESCUES GOING ON.
WE'VE HEARD REPORTS THAT PEOPLE
ARE CALLING, SAYING WE NEED TO
BE RESCUED FROM OUR HOMES.
WHERE THIS CAME ONSHORE, WE ARE
HEARING THAT THE WATER LEVEL
FROM THE STORM SURGE IS AT
PEOPLE'S ROOFS.
BACK TO KATRINA -- I'M NOT
SAYING THIS IS A KATRINA
SITUATION, BECAUSE IT WAS A
DIFFERENT FLOODING SITUATION
FROM THE LEVEES BREAKING.
IF YOU HAVE YOUR HOME, THE WATER
IS UP TO YOUR ROOF, YOU DIDN'T
LEAVE, YOU HAVE NO PLACE TO GO
OTHER THAN TO GET TO THE ATTIC,
KNOCK A HOLE OUT AND WAIT THERE
TO BE RESCUED.
I WANT TO KNOW THEY'RE HEARING
FROM PEOPLE.
THEN WHAT THEIR PLANS ARE TO
HELP PEOPLE WHO DID SAY.
>> YES.
WE WILL ALL BE PAY